hi everyone my name is philip i am a
machine learning engineer at hugging
phase and also the tech lead for our
collaboration with aws today i will show
you in a few minutes how you can run
inference batch transform jobs on amazon
sagemaker using the high interface dlc
in the example we are going to use the
already fine-tuned transformer model
from the hugging phase hub to predict um
the sentiment on tweet data
so let's get started in the example we
are going to use the sagemaker notebook
instance and this is not a requirement
you could also um run your batch shop
from your local machine or using
sagemaker studio
the first step we need to do is to
upgrade our search maker sdk and install
the data sets library i already have
done this
so we can
jump into the data pre-processing part
as mentioned we are going to use a data
set consisting out of tweets basically
it's like around 1800 tweets from
different airline and the data set is
one column
in with the inputs header and then just
the tweets
that that's it
and to run our batch transform job using
the hydrogen face dlc we need to make
sure that we are providing a json line
file instead of a csv file so we need to
convert our csv to a json line file and
we can do this by simply opening the csv
file opening the json line file using
the csv reader from python and then
iterating through each row and creating
a json and adding like the line at the
end additionally we are doing some
processing and we are removing all the
add text
in the data set to create proper
entities instead of having all of the
twitter handle in our data set
afterwards we are uploading our data set
to s3
since when you use search maker batch
transforms you can and need to provide
the inference data either as as free ui
directly with the file or ss3 directory
to your sagemaker transform shop
and after that the or basically the
uploaded json line file
looks like that
then we can the next step is to create a
hiking phase model it is pretty much
similar to what you would do when
creating a sagemaker endpoint we create
our hugging face model instance class
since we are using uh
already fine-tuned model we defining our
hub configuration with our model id and
our task in this case we are using the
twitter roberta base sentiment model
which was fine tuned on 85
million tweets
so
pretty good model i would say and
instead of running the dot deploy method
we are running the dot transformer
method which creates our transformer
class for our batch transform job and in
this we are defining the instance types
we want to use which strategy we want to
use and where the results should be
saved
after we have created our transformer we
can run the transform method which will
then start our batch transform job and
here we provide our s3 data the content
type of the
data set
and um how we want to split the data set
so basically this
will tell sage maker how it should run
inference so in our example we have a
json line file because consisting like
of multiple json file each per row and
with the split type line sagemaker will
send each
line as a separate request with the
content type json to our
yeah endpoint or inference point and
we'll then return it so we have
basically for each row one
request against our sagemaker
and batch transform
this will take now around five minutes
to start and then i guess 30 seconds to
run our
nearly 2000 requests
our batch transform job was successfully
run we can see here the the output logs
of our job firstly our model from the
hub got downloaded and when we scroll
down a bit
here we can see the requests for each
data point we had in our json line file
so as the next step we can use again the
sagemaker
s3 utils to
download our
generated prediction output file from s3
and since we provided
json line file the stagemaker batch
transform job again created a json line
file and this helper function converts
it into a list python lift and then we
can print out the first three results of
it
and as we can see
it worked properly sadly the labels of
the model are not defined so we cannot
see like positive and negative but
um that's something you can change in
the config from your model
if you want to learn more about hugging
face on amazon search maker we have a
nice detailed documentation at
huggingface.com
bye